あくあ
最近の僕のブーム発動するんですけど布袋でカメラを置くというよりて出オチだったら
どうだってるっていう
みなさんお元気でしょうか9月に入って
学校始まって
[音楽]
嫌になってないまあカルゼさんの期末俺は学校嫌だったんだよ
だから夏休みの宿題なんてしたことなかったぜみんなちゃんとしろねさて本題にうつり
ますか皆さん動画のタイプに見てもらったと思うんですけども休みます
たまに安全さんが大したことじゃないですけど全然 youtube が嫌になったと
かやる気がなくなったとかとは全く別なんですけども面で僕が東京に来たかっていうと
そもそもやっぱり忙しくなったっていうのゲーム一つにありますって朝の忙しさが
ちょうど今ピークを迎えていましてでもジェニーさんの忙しいのは狂った奴はも分かっ
てて僕は曲がっててちょっと早めに東京に来て忙しくなる前に
さんどうぞ撮りまくって絶対1日3本とは用品とかウトってたんですよちょっと前まで
どんなストックを見つけた作りまくってもう万全な状態でさあ来い忙しいの声俺が
こんな俺が全部受け止めてやるよ
って感じでもう万全な体制で挑んなんですけど
特区がなくなりましたごめんねほんとそれだけなんです本だそれだけをとそれだけです
よえっアーマー
電池だしたいなーと思ってて頑張ってストックを作ってたんですけども
いよいよいよいよ動画のストックがなくなりロゴを取る時間がほぼないし法的もない
ですね息も切れてしまいついにボクにはちょっと所ぜひどうすることもできない状況に
陥ってしまった訳なのでまぁいつもどうぞ楽しみにしてくださる方で心配されるだと
思ったのでちょっとこういう理由があるんだよ
手の形ヘ強させていただいております製品を込めてちょっと動画をお休みしますという
話ですよ5メディアのタイトルだけ見ると動画やめると思った人もいると思うんです
けど動画は止めませ
止めないんですけどもできれば動画化したいと思います今がんばっているもので全力
出したいので今はひょっとしたら動画が出せないことが多々あるかも知れませんまあ
できれば出したいと思ってますなんか取れたら出すと思うんで質問コーナーもすいませ
ん
バタバタしててまだ取れてません非常にそこは申し訳ないと思っております
まあ側ねもう毎日の動画を休ん
でも質問コーナーもやろうと思ってるんでまたこの忙しいとが終わったら通常運転に
戻ると思うのでまぁ人も見てくださってる皆さん心配詰めてください
僕は研究に行っておりますのでちょっとでお休みが増えるかもしれないんですけども
性 c のままたらそこないとかバンバン出していこうと思っているのでちょっとし
ます
僕は修行に出ると思って行ってもらっ
ても構わないと思っております最近変わったことというと
朝起きるのがすごい早くな
ってことぐらいですかねあと忙しすぎて遊戯を辞めたっていう話です
もうしますお待ちくださいまだ俺頑張るよ頑張れ俺
頑張り俺待っててくれると嬉しいです以上教室セカンドじゃねーよ晴瀬
今できることを頑張ってるいうがあれば動画を出して行きたいと思いますというわけで
お休みいただきます
[音楽]
d っっ
me
ません
[音楽]
ん